[Música]
momento de actualizar la información
económica Ya está lista de nuevo en el
estudio Daniela Blandón bienvenido de
nuevo Muchas gracias Rosa Daniela
empezamos en Estados Unidos porque es
una semana clave para la economía de ese
país y abrimos con una noticia de último
minuto Y es que se acaba de conocer que
la inflación en Estados Unidos en mayo
llegó al 4% interanual esta su cifra más
baja desde marzo de 2021 un dato que
seguramente va a influir en la reunión
de dos días de la reserva Federal que
inició hoy y en la que va a decidir qué
hacer con las tasas de interés pues
vamos a ver en el siguiente gráfico como
casi cada casi 8 de cada 10
inversionistas y economistas esperan que
el Banco Central mantenga estables las
tasas de interés después de 10 aumentos
consecutivos desde marzo de 2022 Y
aprovechando ese respiro que estamos
viendo en la inflación en ese entonces
la tasa de intervención estaban casi 0%
y ahora oscila en un Rango de entre el 5
y el 25 y el 5,25% pero se preguntarán
Cuál es la importancia de esta decisión
en Rosa y es que radica en que esa es la
tasa la que la reserva Federal presta
dinero a los bancos comerciales estos a
su vez trasladan esos costos a los
consumidores y la estrategia de
incrementarla Es que la gente gaste
menos y así los precios tienden a
desacelerarse como efectivamente lo
vienen haciendo
Daniela Pues continuemos con otras
cifras que nos hablan de la economía
mundial vamos con indicadores pues mire
Wall Street abrió al alza el día de hoy
están muy animados por este dato de
inflación porque mire están 4% hoy pero
en junio llegó a estar en un 9,2% del
año pasado esto fue su pico más alto en
cuatro décadas y el mercado está viendo
una especie de respiro en este indicador
también vemos como en Europa las bolsas
o los principales índices de las bolsas
también operan al alza todos pues
esperando por supuesto que va a decidir
la reserva Federal el día de mañana y en
Asia También estamos viendo como el
níquel de Tokio sube más del 1% 1,8% ya
cerró esta bolsa todos están desde luego
pendientes de lo que hagan sus
respectivos bancos centrales esta semana
especialmente el Banco Central de
Estados Unidos pues Daniela Mientras
tanto nosotros estamos pendientes de la
gira de úrsulay en la presidenta de la
comisión europea por América Latina con
el tema del acuerdo entre Unión Europea
y mercosur como plato principal en esta
agenda Qué se sabe pues este es un
acuerdo que tardó más de 20 años en ser
negociado entre la Unión Europea y los
países de mercosur que son Argentina
Brasil Paraguay y Uruguay y solamente le
hace falta su ratificación que está
pendiente desde 2019 si llegara a entrar
en vigencia incluiría unos 800 millones
de personas y representaría una cuarta
parte del pib mundial con un comercio
bilateral que al año sumaría unos 100
mil millones de dólares la preocupación
principal de países como Francia es la
de en el Amazonas el bloque europeo ya
ha tomado medidas como obligar a los
importadores a que demuestran que los
productos que están llevando desde
América Latina no provienen de esas
prácticas ahora lo que ha pasado es que
las partes confían en que el pacto vaya
a ver la luz verde a más tardar a
finales de este año por lo menos eso fue
lo que dijo úrsulay en su visita a
Brasil y Mientras tanto en otras
regulaciones del bloque comunitario
avanza la Unión Europea en regular la
llamada economía chic esta economía se
refiere Rosa a los nuevos modelos de
trabajo que han surgido en los últimos
años que distan de los tradicionales
estamos hablando por ejemplo de los
repartidores de empresas como Uber
Delivery Food o globo entre otros la
Unión Europea lleva meses tratando de
regularlo para garantizar la igualdad de
condiciones entre quienes trabajan en
oficinas y quienes lo hacen En
plataformas en línea los países miembros
hicieron una serie de ajustes a un
borrador que ya tenían y que va a
discutido en el parlamento Próximamente
lo que buscan es que estas personas sean
consideradas trabajadoras si cumplen con
ciertos criterios Como por ejemplo que
los supervisen a través de medios
electrónicos o también a quienes
restrinjan su capacidad para elegir su
horario de trabajo entre otros Uber por
su parte ya rechazó la iniciativa
como han demostrado muchos países de
Europa Hay mejores formas de defender
los valores sociales europeos sin
eliminar la independencia y la
flexibilidad que la mayoría de los
trabajadores de las plataformas dicen
querer
Daniela y en otras noticias China y
Honduras estrechan lazos comerciales No
pues china dio luz verde a la
importación de granos de café también a
plátanos desde Honduras esté anuncio fue
hecho en medio del encuentro de Xiomara
Castro con jijing Pink Esta es la
primera visita oficial de un mandatario
al país asiático Tegucigalpa tendrá
ahora también una embajada en China
después de que en marzo anunciara la
reapertura de diplomáticas después de
que este país centroamericano
oficializara la ruptura de las
relaciones que mantenía contra Iván
desde 1941 bueno Daniela pues estaremos
atentos a estas relaciones de china con
Honduras uno de los últimos países en
romper relaciones con Taiwán para
girarse hacia china Claro que sí Mañana
nos vemos acá para hablar de la reserva
Federal Porque seguramente no habrá
decisión pero si estará todo mucho más
claro con este dato de inflación pues
esperamos con estas noticias Daniela
hasta mañana